[Music]
let's go to jordan in houston my
hometown
go astros what's up jordan
hey john not much how are you doing we
are partying that's not true i'm not
partying at all actually um i'm sitting
at a desk talking to you on the phone
hey there's four awesome people from all
over america out here watching too we
have a packed studio audience here what
are you up to
uh just uh hanging out and excited to
talk to you so very cool i guess i can
just kind of go ahead and uh kind of get
going here and let you know what i'm
calling about yeah tell me what's up um
so here's where i'm at i kind of just
want to see if you can help guide me in
the right direction
in my past i've just never been very
good with friends
friends has never been my strong point
um i know exactly for me kind of where
the issue started when i was young
so if that kind of helps you a little
bit absolutely
if you do i mean do you kind of want to
know like where it kind of started for
me
yeah uh before we do that let's do this
um when you say
um so you you and i talked a little bit
earlier for a minute before we had and
we had to reshoot some stuff you were
mentioning that you you have friends and
you start friendships and they end in
ash what does that mean
so for me it means that they end in ash
i
and this is why i'm in therapy now this
is why i'm working on this but it ends
up being that i end up
abruptly ending the friendship there's
no reconciliation there's no nothing i'm
just i think too scared to kind of
if that makes sense do you end it over
an issue like somebody's like hey i got
vaccinated and you're like you're an
idiot i hate you
or do you just wake up on a tuesday and
you're like
you're lame it's kind of it's kind of
like it'll build up over time
and i never really say anything about it
what builds up
so
uh
i mean i'll take my most uh i think
shining example of this um i had a
10-year friendship right
this
uh i ended up living with this girl we
were friends since high school it was
really awesome you know i ended up
moving to texas and living with her for
a while
ended up meeting my husband everything
like that like texas is great right so
over the time that we had lived together
the environment that i was living in
with her just became
really unsafe really unstable really
scary um what does that mean and
then so like for instance one of the
roommates uh
threatened to shoot up drug dealers and
then the drug dealers came back and said
we're going to shoot everyone in your
entire house
so kind of thing so sometimes i talk to
folks they're like it's just not safe
there's cheetos everywhere
and
then there's
uh it's not safe because someone's gonna
murder us so okay so you're this is
legitimate not safe okay
right and so it kind of ended up being
and in the middle of this i was planning
my wedding right so i had a lot going on
yeah
so my now husband and i ended up moving
out of this house we you know got out of
there we're safe no one was harmed thank
goodness um and then it ended up being
that
she was trying to control planning my
wedding and i
and i think i just got to a point where
i just couldn't handle her anymore
and it was like less than a month before
my wedding ended up cutting the
friendship off no nothing no
i just said i can't i can't have you in
my life anymore and i just cut her off
so did you uninvite her from your
wedding
she was going to be my bridesmaid one of
my bridesmaids
you just broke up with her
i 100 yeah i just broke up with her and
it makes me sad to this day like i've
written like a letter that i haven't
sent you know like
that kind of stuff but i think what i'm
just scared of now and here's where i am
now is that i've made a new friend and
i'm scared of this happening again like
i'm scared of
repeating history you know yeah
so
take me back quickly take me back to you
said you knew where this stuff all comes
from
where does it come from so
you were right so it started when i was
i believe i was like 10 right so i went
to a 4-h camp over the summer one year
4-h camp were just chickens and goats
everywhere
no it was like a 4-h camp like we were
hiking and then we would like go
swimming
it was kind of one of those camps okay
um
so what ended up happening was i was
friends with these two girls like we
went to camp we met we like hung out
we were supposed to go to a dance one
night and um we like that morning we
were all like kind of coordinating our
outfits like we were like this is gonna
be fun and we were excited and
everything
we went to dinner
before the dance and the two girls
came up to me like i couldn't find them
for some reason and they come up to me
randomly and they both together said
every other word of one sentence so if
you can kind of picture that in your
head
they said one sentence but each girl was
saying one word what was this
so they came up to me and they said we
don't want to be your friend anymore we
don't want to hang out with you anymore
we don't want to go to the dance with
you
and in that moment i'm like
of course i was upset like i like you
know cried and everything like i was ten
i don't know you know
and then um that's kind of where it
started
where what started
where i think my issues with friendships
really started
i would be willing to bet money i'm not
very wealthy i'm not wealthy at all i'd
be willing to bet you that's not where
it started
um
my guess is if you and i sat down and
kind of put that may be a contributing
factor
kids are wildly resilient
those kind of things can be a thorn
um
but
all that to say is this
understanding
like to use the language from the book
owning what happened owning the fact
that you have a history of either
friends breaking up with you or you
breaking up with friends
okay
that's the important part there
that you recognize you want to be in
relationship with people and somehow it
always implodes
and now we're at a stage where we have
to acknowledge reality you have found
yourself relatively alone
and you found yourself always something
happens in these friendships
um
how truthful can i be with you can it be
super truthful
that's why i called okay yeah
whenever somebody calls me usually this
call is about dating right i i date i've
dated 10 people and it always blows up
spectacularly whatever my question is
always
you're the common denominator in all 10
of these relationships
what are you bringing to the table so i
would ask you that in this similar
situation
because at the end of the day you can't
control these other people in your life
what are you bringing to the table that
is making these relationships extra
combustible or
um
what are you bringing to the table
that puts this pressure on a
relationship to exist or not exist
um
that's a really good question i think um
because here's what i don't want you to
do i don't want you to keep looking at
the finish line because there's not a
finish line with friendships or the
finish line is death okay
and
friendships take a
an up and down all over the place
role depending on what season you're in
some of my closest friends on the planet
during i've been
traveling all over the country speaking
at companies and events and things like
that i just don't see my friends very
much we text and then when i'm home i
see them much more regularly
and i was just visiting some guys that i
haven't seen in several years and we
picked up and we were running around
this dude's ranch in texas
we picked up just like it was yesterday
right but now we're just older and more
wrinkled and dumber and then right so
some of it's about season but
so i don't want you to focus on the
metric i just want you to focus on
the connectivity what are you bringing
to that connectivity
that makes you feel like this thing's
going to always end in ash which then
certifies this i mean assures that it's
always going into nash
i think what i'm bringing to the table
is the expectation that it's going to at
some point
honestly um
i i think i just kind of expect it to
end at some point and i
yeah i mean it's sorry i wish i had a
better answer i'm like i'm stuck
actively thinking about this
that's a great thing so you've probably
heard this analogy there's a there's a
bow hunting an archery analogy that
comes from skiing
when when you have those downhill skiers
that are running through the forest
you have to you can't look at the trees
because if you look at the trees you'll
hit them every time you have to look at
the space between the trees and that's
how those skiers fly through those those
forests
and when you're doing archery or your
bow hunting you can't look at the limbs
and try not to hit the limbs you have to
look zero in on your target
and that's how you
right so you go through all stuff if you
head into new friendships head into new
relationships and by the way your
husband is a friendship of some sort and
my guess is he's probably put this
burden on him too
looking forward to that when does this
end is that is that true
i wish it wasn't but i think part like
in the back of my head i keep thinking
okay like he's gonna leave me eventually
or you know something like that i know
that won't happen or i hope it doesn't
happen but i don't
you know what i mean yeah um
besides those friends who who who took
off on you
besides knuckleheads at a camp who took
off on you
um
no one
no one really left me per se i mean i
know i grew up in a household but there
was a lot of yelling let me let me back
up the other side someone doesn't have
to leave you who didn't welcome you
because there's
trauma can be both what ha what somebody
said to you what they did to you but it
can also be what didn't happen to you
somebody should have told you this house
only runs because you're in it someone
should have told you
um
i love you
and i'm glad you're my kid
yeah no one ever really told me that i
mean i i god i love you a lot but i
never really got like i'm grateful
you're here i never really got like
you're you're a essential part of this
household i grew up with a lot of
yelling um so let's not necessarily at
me but watching like my dad yell at my
sister growing up that was really hard
yeah and for a kid you can hear the
words i love you and your body can react
to the unsafe environment with which you
live and that creates chaos
right right and so that chaos ping-pongs
through every relationship you're gonna
have so your choice now is this
is to say okay those things happened
what am i gonna do now
and what i would tell you is it sounds
like when playing semantics and i'm not
there the the difference between how
incredible can me and my husband make
our marriage
versus how do i keep from losing this
thing
one of those is a performance and a
checklist and a set of metrics
the other
is a free-for-all
into a new adventure you see what i'm
saying now that new adventure is going
to be filled with potholes and routes
that you trip on and metrics that you
need to keep up with but it's it's it's
the other way around and i would tell
you that with friendships
entering into a friendship with
expectations that this is all going to
come down some day
it's like dude we're just getting coffee
you know what i mean right um
and when a friend lets you down which a
hundred percent of them will
and i have let my friends down
the relationship it's
if you go looking for when does this end
you will find confirmation of the ending
everywhere
if you go into
like
we're just we just ride or die this is
just who we are
there will become seasons when y'all
when you all fade out and that's okay
and then there'll be seasons like we're
just not friends and you're like oh man
we've been hung out in three years
that's just that's just how life works
but there's always gonna be a core group
of people that you circle back to and
you circle back to because you're
intentional about it and when they let
you down then you can have that hard
conversation hey you were taking over my
wedding stop
you're my friend
and then they might say
you're a
train wreck
you're always playing playing things and
it's a mess and we're staring so here's
the example in my wedding you ready
um
i
was real against like i don't want any
of my friends have to spend any money so
i was like we're not doing tuxes we're
not doing internet stuff i want y'all
just to wear clothes that you already
have and so i came up with these outfits
that were like white shirts and and like
short sleeve shirts because it was hot
outside in texas where i got married and
like khaki pants everybody's got that
and a group of my buddies
came and two of them in particular said
hey by the way we've all changed what
we're wearing because you have us
dressed like idiots we're not doing this
and um by the way you're gonna go get a
jacket too because you're not a [ __ ]
you're getting married so
here's the thing
i wasn't waiting for them to screw up so
that i could announce i knew it my
friendship's over
i i said hey i want to do it differently
and they said we love you enough that 20
years from now when your kids look back
at those pictures they're going to have
less respect for you because you made us
dress like morons and so uh we love you
enough to hold you accountable to it
and i went thank y'all thank you you
know what i mean and so there's a moment
when you can say hey you're taking over
my wedding and your friend can say
that's because it's a mess and it's
gonna go
horribly awry or
i'm sorry right you see what i'm saying
because there's not all that pressure
there's not a finish line that we're
looking to get to so here let me say
this
you said you have a new friend tell me
about this new friend
uh she's awesome we
we have a lot in common we're both
tattooed so that's cool
we both
have dogs we both don't have kids yet
you know we're both
fairly young marriages um
that kind of thing we both i mean we've
been kind of like confiding in each
other a little bit like we've been we've
been finding those uh
areas in our life where it's like
me too you know what i mean and so
that's been kind of nice to have that
person in that way so that's it's it's
been great i mean it's only been a
couple of months but i mean
do you feel the pressure you're putting
on this already
i do like you've created a checklist for
it already so let me be like
um i have tattoos i just don't have i
have them under my clothes right so you
can't see them
and i've got friends who are tatted
tattooed all over the place and i've got
great friends that have zero and they
make fun of me
and i've got friends does that make
sense
so what i would tell you is
instead of looking for a bunch of oh
yeah me too oh yeah me too oh yeah me
too
ask yourself how your body feels in
their company
okay ask yourself like when i say
something
kind of vulnerable to this person i feel
safe or if uh i don't feel comfortable
that's a totally different question then
oh look we have the same shoes oh look
we have the same hair oh look we have
this like that's a recipe for disaster
because there's gonna come a point when
the next election rolls around and
you're like i'm super voting for so and
so and she'll be like i'm voting for
this person and you're like there it is
the end
and you'll be like son of a and then
it's gonna be over to be a bit don't do
if she's your friend you can be like oh
man
i think you're an idiot and she'll be
like nah you're the idiot and y'all can
have a discussion and then you can have
some more nachos you see what i'm saying
yeah i do so let me say this
all all relationship 100 of them
is a risk
i don't care if you're 85 and you've
been married for 40 years
40 years in one day when you tell your
husband hey i was hoping we could travel
here
and he might say i ain't traveling where
don't you know the liberals or whatever
he's gonna say
um
you just took a risk and you got shot
down
right you're 80 and you're running into
the last years of your life and you just
want to go see what san francisco looks
like and my husband ain't taking you
right right you just run into that
that's a risk it's always a risk
meeting new friends is always a risk it
just is and so what i would tell you and
if nobody's ever told you this i'm sorry
i hate that i'm the first one
you're worth being friends with
and you're gonna be a i promise you
jordan you're a weirdo everybody is
and
somebody will be friends with your
little weirdo ness
and or they'll put up with your
weirdoness and you'll put up with their
weirdoness
but trying to perform and checklist your
way through a series of friendships is a
fool's errand it's going to end in ash
every time so the
i'm kind of on a kick lately
um and it started with me just changing
my diet up some and i'll talk about that
in a future episode but here's what i
would challenge you on
you've done friendships this way how old
are you now
i just turned 30. okay
20 plus years this is how you've done
friendships
yeah i want to challenge you
to look in your around your environment
and acknowledge reality this is where
you've landed with basically zero and
your husband
commit to trying something different
okay let's commit to stop looking for
the ending
when you find yourself tell like saying
he's probably just gonna leave
stop that thought say no no stop stop
stop he's not leaving he's my husband
and then be curious about why am i
saying that
what is it about my day
what's going on in my life when i start
to say things like that is it when he's
busy or is it when i
um
want to sleep together and he's
playing video games as friends and i
started is it when bills are due is it
when i'm hungry is it when i'm tired
start asking yourself when did these
negative thoughts come into my head
and stop them before they come stories
because when they become stories then
your body responds with the cascaded
chemicals now you're off to the races
and so let's stop them way up ahead and
always know
i'm worth being friends with and this
person that your friend like
she may become your best friend of all
time ever or she just may be a great
human being in this season and then
y'all will both get get pregnant and
you'll be like oh gosh you're one of
those moms
and she's gonna be like oh my gosh she's
one of those moms and then you're gonna
find another gang right you see what i'm
saying
yeah take the pressure off
here's what i'd love you to do um
go back through some people in your in
your friendships in the past that um
that you loved and that are quote
unquote in ash
see if there's one or two or three of
them you can pick up a phone and call
and don't facebook them
be it have a human interaction but reach
out and
call and say hey let's go get coffee
and
or um let's go
x or y let's go do something
and some of those friendships those
those old friendships may need to the
conversation needs to start with i just
need to start this conversation by
saying i'm sorry i screwed that up
and i'm working through a lot of
childhood stuff
not an excuse it just happened i did it
and i was rude and i want to start fresh
or something i love you and i'm sorry i
don't hang out anymore but i miss you i
hope you're doing well
and
see what it feels like what it feels
like to go back and say the words i'm
sorry to go back to people that you have
deep roots with and say man we got off
sideways but this tree didn't fall all
the way over and uh let's hang out and
with this new friend
stop going to the checklist
just hang out man just hang out enjoy
your life
enjoy your life enjoy your husband y'all
create something amazing together don't
try not to break up and hope you can
tell the difference there